for those that aren't familiar last
night during the show we got swatted and
that means someone called the police and
claimed there was an active shooter on
the property and that people had been
hurt
during the show luke was talking and you
can see an officer walk past the camera
and then walk out and it seems to go
very quickly i walk out of the room and
then uh after we realized what happened
you know lydia's like look we got
swatted i get up and i go talk to the
cop there were two out there and we come
back a lot of people
didn't get the full picture from that
they believe there was just a couple
cops who walked in waved and left there
were eight cops that i ended up uh i saw
i think i saw five downstairs when i
went back out and said what was going on
and asked them politely to leave and
then there were also state troopers and
there was another jurisdiction i think a
sheriff's department
they were all asked politely to leave i
said i don't want you here without a
warrant so uh as to what happened we
don't know who did it we do have a
couple different firms legal firms
filing everything and we're getting into
high gear to figure out what we can
preserve body camera footage the 911
call people have already released the
the the police radio calls a couple of
them
and what i can say is
i uh uh there were a few theories as to
what happened and why we got swatted now
i'm sure whoever did it it's probably
listening i don't know what their
intention was some people were saying
it's just it's the internet it's trolls
it's what happens perhaps
some people were thinking that it's
related to some trolling that's been
going on but uh one of the theories that
we had to discuss was whether or not it
was related to marjorie taylor green's
appearance on the show i did mention it
the other day
and after the show i didn't want to you
know
contact her team and and drag her into
something she was here the day before on
the fifth
not on not the day we got we got swatted
but you know luke mentioned it's
probably a good idea for security
reasons just to let people know like hey
this happened and uh i can't speak for
marjorie taylor green and what her
opinion of this is but what was conveyed
to me
is that she's been receiving a large
amount of death threats as of the sixth
and that leads me to believe that what
happened to us was directly related to
us hosting her i don't know for sure i'm
not saying it's a guarantee i'm not
saying i believe 100
i'm saying it seems probable and the
reason is
we film these live episodes
we start at 8pm we end at 10. at 10 when
we end the live stream is when youtube
says it's published and it sends out
notifications slowly to a bunch of
people that means for a lot of people
you'll wake up in the morning and get a
notification you know tim cast irelle
with guest marjorie taylor green
on this day the morning of january 6
when people are getting this
notification that we hosted her that's
the day she was getting slammed with
death threats
so i don't think it's a coincidence then
that on that same day that she's getting
death threats we also get swatted and it
may be because some people either the
individual mistakenly thought we were
currently hosting her on the show or it
was just they saw the show the
notification or just someone mentioned
it and they said screw these people and
they end up swatting us ultimately we
have no idea why it happened but i think
that seems to be the most likely
i don't know i don't know for sure and i
don't want to um
i i don't know i don't want to make it
seem like we're saying it's def it's
definitive we just don't know but that
seems likely and uh i don't know if you
guys wanted to add anything and well you
know of course this is a very serious
matter we were very lucky that one of
our employees was outside and prevented
the swatting prevent and prevented the
raid um i i don't know if the officer
was waiting for backup or just waiting
to assess the situation
but if you okay but but you know if the
officer was waiting to assess the
situation that was the right move to to
make there and it prevented a lot of
people from getting hurt so shout out to
all the employees that were out there
that are professional that didn't panic
didn't freak out and also started
filming the police right away when they
entered here
there's you know a lot of questions
surrounding that as well but it was
three different jurisdictions a large
number of police officers we couldn't
even count all the police cars that were
here so this was a major incident and
luckily uh it didn't get escalated and
we got a number of things at play and
we're gonna do our best to find out
what's going on here there were also
some of our staff reported police
vehicles driving down the road back and
forth so aside from the eight or however
many vehicles were in the driveway
and then there were i believe at least
eight officers walking around maybe more
there are actually other officers
driving around because what people need
to realize about this so i can't give
too much information away because
there's an ongoing investigation but
this is we're very close to washington
dc
the people who live in this area
many of them are
politicos political lawyers um people
who work in uh they work in politics
they work in dc right
so we're about an hour west of
washington dc
this area of the tri-state which is
virginia maryland and west virginia and
the harpers ferry area has a ton
of dc commuters these people are fairly
you know democrat types they're uh
heavily involved in politics they're
well connected many of them are
high-powered lawyers and the police went
to their homes so people around here are
extremely pissed off what you need to
understand is we are not in a densely
populated area so when someone says you
know my address is one zero zero fake
street the cops are like well in the
span of two miles there's you know five
houses and if we get one number wrong
then it could be the house a few miles
down so they got to send out a ton of
cops
they had to go to a bunch of different
houses that are far away from here and
do wellness checks and all these places
so it wasn't just what we were
experiencing we got the brunt of it we
get all the cops but my understanding is
that the cops actually drove down very
far to other homes and were knocking on
doors and people are are let's just say
mildly perturbed no kidding at being
disturbed over what would happen and
being asked questions and the cops
saying you know we're getting a report
of a murder-suicide and we need to check
your home i don't know to what extent
they went and checked other houses but i
can say that people are uh my
understanding is that people are angry
and
what i was told is that
i was told we can't tell you how
but we absolutely will find out who did
this
so this is not the area that you want to
be screwing with you know some some
people out here are like extremely
wealthy hot well-connected
you know political individuals and this
was it was bigger than just us you know
just this house you know what bothers me
about this one of the things that
bothers me about this is the oxygen
circumstance clause like fourth
amendment of the constitution you have
the right to protection from
unreasonable search and seizure but
apparently if there's an exigent
circumstance if there's some sort of
emergency
then
it's reasonable to search for the cops
to bust into your house and search you
were you were mentioning that ricada law
said there was no exit this is this is
what i learned from mercado law last
night actually this is the stuff that's
coming from his show last night which i
would suggest going and watching um yeah
if they come here and they think well
maybe this is a swatting then they
basically there are no accident
circumstances at that point so if they
said that if there's if there's evidence
that they were on the police scanner
saying we don't we think this might be a
swatting but they came in anyway he said
it's probably a swaddle but they came in
anyway he said we're pretty sure this is
a swag they're pretty sure it's a
swatting but they came in anyway they
may have overstepped this uh exigent
thing i'm still on their side here i
want to work with these guys and the
local cops and everything but this
oxygen thing is very i mean you want to
talk about totalitarian
abilities to search your house and and
if you have a pile of cash on your table
and they take it because of civil asset
forfeiture i don't know if they're
allowed to do that i got an
advertisement on instagram today for gag
coasters that have lines of white powder
on them it was on instagram and it said
gag gifts
and uh
i was just thinking when i'm scrolling
on instagram i'm like what if we had
something like that imagine the the
issue is
there's a reason why i don't want
strangers in my home i don't care if
they're a police officer or not a police
officer i that you know when we vet
people when they come here we know who
they are now sometimes cops are
criminals not all cops are good people
cops are just people so i understand
they're coming here because they got a
report they want to they want to help
make sure everyone's okay and everything
like that but once they figured that out
when three people four people actually
in the driveway told them oh yeah
everything's fine and you're wrong and
you can't come in and they said yeah
we're pretty sure sweating now we're
going to come in anyway i'm like dude
that pisses me off a lot
it is so crazy to me that you need to
say something like i really don't want
strangers in my house i feel like you
shouldn't have to say that and i i was
gonna ask i don't know if anybody knows
and i didn't have a chance to look it up
but do we know if swatting is a felony
in the state of maryland i don't know
about this damn pretty sure it's it's
multiple felonies interesting yeah i
think i think it's not only uh like
attempted murder yeah of course uh
it depends on the pro i mean it would be
the d.a interpretation of whether it's
attempted murder i certainly think it is
everyone people have often said it is
but um filing a false police report you
know very serious and multiple times so
that's that's got to be i mean look you
got jesse smallett he got six counts of
fellaini disorderly conduct for the
false police reports right in this
instance the severity of it sending
police officers and you're putting in
you're putting the cops in fear of death
you're instilling the fear of death in
them i mean these guys were probably
adrenaline going a million miles an hour
you can hear like in the police radio
that people were posting online when
when they're like you know we got this
caller that call you hear the sirens on
one of the guys radio like they're
rushing here yeah so these guys are
probably like here we go man this is
something bad and their hearts going a
million miles an hour they think they
could be walking into a deadly scenario
so i wouldn't say it's attempted murder
on that on their regard but you're
certainly you know putting them in
extreme distress well it's such a waste
of resources too if nothing else if
you're even if you're not like
attempting to murder someone via swat
and saying that i mean treating a swat
visit as attempted murder that's wild to
me like you have to know that they're
overusing force in that i think it's
right i think we need to we need to call
it uh exactly as it is
they tried to kill ian oh yep
clearly
yeah
ian was about to run to the bathroom
yeah and if we didn't have
our staff walking outside at that exact
moment and the cops came in with their
guns ready
going through the house and ian runs
down the hall to go to the bathroom
because what you got to understand is
during the show when we're live
we have we have a bathroom in studio to
sound proof but ian's not going to be
able to go around to the table so he's
got another door he'd have to run to the
bathroom as quickly as possible yeah
because we're live he runs the show
you don't want to you know just leave
the show for 10 minutes you're going to
run and run out
if the cops had walked up the stairs and
it's dark and ian's running down the
hallway of this building to go to the
bathroom and see him flying through and
they're like what is this thing and
they're like some dudes running at us in
this type of way yeah that's not even
funny man i i almost did like for 10
minutes before they arrived i was like i
got to hit the bathroom and i was like
well this conversation's good so i
stayed and i was listening for a while
and then they came in i could have been
easily out there running around they
were here at 8 20. stop stop they were
here at 8 27.
so the the someone so the call was made
at 8 20. the cops arrived at 8 27
that was when andy our cto walks out
into the parking lot and he turns left
he's heading towards our bar in our
outdoor skatepark area and then he stops
and decides i'm going to go see who's
this person in the driveway and that's
when they realized it was the police so
this is around 8 29 or so
i think it was only about two or three
minutes later met the the backup arrives
at that point the cops would have
started getting ready and moving quickly
to come inside maybe they would have
gotten on the on the megaphone or
whatever and i don't know exactly what
their protocol would have been
but that was i would say around 10
minutes before everything went down
it's very possible that
yeah i'll just say look nothing nothing
bad happened because work
is an office it's a company so people
were doing their jobs and were just like
what's going on but this could have been
way way way worse in some states in some
jurisdictions the protocol literally is
bust down the door with your firearms up
in the air ready to take down any kind
of threat and there have been a lot of
people that died because of swatting
let's just be real and honest with
ourselves this is some people say a
prank but you know this is something
that of course is serious as well and
has led to people dying it's terrorism
yeah because i'll i'll say
there's uh people
the craziest thing to me is the people
who want to uh try and like
look
we had marjorie taylor green on the show
the same day we are getting swatted
she's getting inundated with death
threats it was january 6 right so it
seems obvious that's a day that people
are going to be screaming at her and
coming after her and she came out with
matt gates they issued a statement
and so it was the day after we hosted
her this is when we get a good portion
of the views the next day the podcast
throughout the day gets a ton of traffic
and it was with her
and then at 8 20 20 minutes after the
show starts we get swatted i think it's
terrorism regardless even if it's not
political it's if you send something
some cops to go scare someone that's an
act of terror i mean i don't want to
overuse the word but it's domestic
terrorism they're trying to get cops to
kill you yeah they didn't they they
didn't call the cops and say well
they're trying to get you to kill the
cop it's insane they're trying to get
someone hurt yes
and apparently this individual what they
called uh several different departments
and a suicide hotline two different um
they wanted them to come in here guns
drawn yeah yeah like as fast as they
could yep
terrorism is crazy that's nuts i don't
call for terrorism much but that is a
form of terrorism to do that to someone
you don't call for it much i don't call
for it ever
i don't like calling the word out
because it's so overused in the last 20
years um this and that can be like
january 6th the people looking at the
wall meemaw that word's been in my head
for like 24 hours all the mimosas or
mamas or whatever me mom looking around
it's like the bumbling you know that
they weren't terrorists but they're
getting held for suspected terrorism
like that's i think that's a gross
misjustice there's a lot of a lot of
issues with the oxygen circumstances and
entering the property so what really
pisses me off is that
that someone can lie and the police can
completely disregard four people outside
saying nothing is going on and you're
wrong when it when it completely
contradicts what they were told on the
phone they were told the phone one guy
had harmed two people and was gonna harm
himself and they encounter four people
three guys and one woman all saying this
is a place of business we're live right
now in studio it's not happening and
they said yeah pretty sure
now we're going to come in anyway no
that's that's complete bs i reject that
100 yeah but this is so clearly a form
of intimidation i think that's what
ian's getting out when he talks about
terrorism it doesn't even have to be
political this is so obviously
intimidation and whatever motivated this
it's obviously just to try maybe to get
us to shut up to distract us to get our
minds off some other topic maybe it was
because of a marjorie taylor green
interview but the timing was crazy with
that one but well luke didn't get
distracted or perturbed at all i mean he
was no no he was focused laser focused
exactly i was like i love that dead air
we can't have damage
we were just talking on one of the
members podcasts how like you know the
guests will be talking and then it'll go
they'll stop talking and then i'll just
look at luke look at me he's like oh so
anyway anyway
ready to go i don't know how i'm able to
do it but like i'm just able to continue
the train of thought as i'm like looking
at everything that's happening and it's
just kind of continuing the conversation
it's weird but i'm going to start
looking at linda yeah just pitch it to
me
so we we've got a couple different
very uh excellent legal firms
already
filing paperwork like crazy we're going
to be we're going for all the records
the police reports we want to know what
they said before what they said after we
want the 9-1-1 call we want to hear the
person's voice
and then we'll we're going to you know
as i'm told
they can't tell me how but they're going
to find out who did this that's kind of
scary i know
well
listen listen look let's get serious for
a second we had a sitting member of
congress on this show and the next day
someone swatted us which is fbi's on it
i mean i i'd have to imagine it's i'd
say so yeah and as the person made the
phone call from out of the jurisdiction
if it includes we're
we're uh uh literally 30 seconds from
the state border yeah so this could be
that this could be a federal issue
already this is definitely a demon
yeah yeah i was just like
we're not going to tell you how but
interesting we will find out i'm lying
i'm like oh man thanks empire
i'll pay my taxes
as bad as everything is i'm not i'm not
completely i don't believe necessarily
believe it's true i certainly believe
there's powerful interests look their
attitude is we can fight with each other
but don't you screw with us you like
look at what happened on january 6 all
of these members of congress are like we
don't care if you're out in the streets
hitting each other but when you come to
our house oh oh so they so i i don't
know maybe maybe they don't like mtg but
i'd also imagine they might be saying
like we may not like her but the last
thing i want is to go on a show to
promote my campaign and have this happen
so they're going to be like find this
person yeah shut it down that's
interesting yeah i wonder if they'll use
her to try to kind of send a message i'd
be fascinated to see what happens and
i'm curious if the fbi is on it and i do
want to know what these law firms have
to say about the exigent thing i want to
know if there's like a case there to be
made
well i mean i don't know what we're
gonna do i mean i know but nothing
happened they left so there's like
there's no standing for anything like
what what are our damages but like that
that's all my home i think we gotta
remodel the whole thing how dare they
you can a government can redefine what a
word means and if they want to redefine
exigent to mean like any
thought that maybe someone's sneezing
inside their house
they're actually pretty specific there's
like three agent circumstances they're
very specific and the one that we fell
under was uh imminent harm was was about
to occur but they clearly didn't believe
that was the case right which is why to
be determined it's gonna be other ones
are like red pursuit hot pursuit laws
like if you if you think the guy's gonna
get away like if they're in a car that's
like considered a hot pursuit thing so
because they might be gone in a second
if you don't act thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you